hey Phil I got you a chicken sandwich oh
thanks ah chicken sandwich yeah you know
what why don't I make you a chicken
sandwich so we're gonna start off with a
beautiful chicken breast which we brine
for 24 hours in our secret Taiwanese
marinade that is traditionally used for
popcorn chicken we have these
custom-made bolo buns which are like a
Chinese traditional pineapple bun
because it looks like a pineapple and we
get these made locally we use a Napa
cabbage slaw we mix it with our Thai
Basil aioli which is House made and then
we lay down some Chinese pickle
cucumbers instead of the typical Dill
cucumbers and then we put it all
together and we have a beautiful
Taiwanese inspired Fried Chicken
Sandwich bam wow cheers